boulet kev podcast got my guy hitboy in
the building go watch the interview we
just dropped but you know my guys got
the new song corsa out go watch the
video it's time to get to the bars man
sorry yes sir let's get it yeah
shot my brother esco
kv3 on the way yes sir in a real way
[ __ ] in their early 30s use my life as
a restaurant as long as the family
together [ __ ] her online presents the
surf club hs 87 fl studio still my
choice of weapon double gave me a 9 when
life gave me lessons in the field like
aryan when he played with the texans
long greyhound bus rise to texas taught
me the most about reverence how the man
don't respect us another [ __ ] on
display painful pops being away still
[ __ ] with me today collect cars
coming in again the never ending story
of a denver lane blood gang member in
its glory [ __ ] thinking sweet cuz i
got nominations and some grammys trying
hard to sleep through the turbine and
landing putting time on the phone so i
could speak to my daddy when they
knocked him again i shed tears in miami
puff bought me a trap phone hold on
email feel like i've been like before so
many visits to jail they thought i came
up i'm barely tipping the scale [ __ ]
wishing i fall instead of wishing me
well
appreciation turn to expectation
sometimes you gotta x them out without
the explanation what's the over under
they label me underrated i had to bet on
myself spent the weekend in vegas life
hard but you learn to love it painting
hardships to make a grown man crying
public if i care about you enough i'ma
shoot you some game it's up to you what
you do with it og told me the same damn
i piped up the penmanship when the
emotions come you gotta remember who you
dealing with this [ __ ] ain't by
coincidence i stayed down diligent
straight in and out the crooked finally
caught my foot in did what they said i
couldn't blowing it down and georgie
o'board did i answer my calling i had to
click over say i'm sorry to everybody
who thought they knew me before i ain't
changed up i'm just the better me truly
i'm more locked in than i've ever been
2022 president i ain't with the back
peddling he'll be direct for the
scheduling
if it's something to be sold my
brother's gonna sell it when they have a
hard time complimenting you they jealous
can't be moving careless [ __ ] talking
reckless wrong as hell but go off in the
world so lost thought my dog worked for
nike how to get them bowls off and being
real is what i'm resting on when we take
our steps we gotta know what we stepping
on
yeah
okay yes sir
hey boy
course out right now
let's go hey i know you just watched a
brand new freestyle presented to you by
our good folks at lrg don't forget if
you go to lrg right now the website will
be right there broom l
r dash g dot com
use the promo code bootleg and you'll
get thirty percent off your order that's
l dash
l-r-g.com you'll see it right down there
save 30 off your order by putting in
that promo code bootleg and shout out to
lrg we got another freestyle coming next
week